mexican citizens took to the polls on
sunday for a first ever national
referendum to decide the political fate
of president andres manuel lopez obrador
outside this polling station in mexico
city many seemed eager to cast their
votes
i think the most important thing is that
this exercise will keep happening in the
future
independent of this president in the
future this will be an opportunity that
citizens didn't have in the past
i think it's good and positive it makes
our society politically active and
that's a valuable thing
the referendum on the presidency is a
divisive topic in mexico one that has
sparked demonstrations both for and
against
some critics are calling the referendum
unnecessary given that president lopez
obrador already has a nearly 60 percent
approval rating others have argued the
referendum is being manipulated by
president lopez obrador's party to rally
supporters ahead of the next
presidential election in 2024.
in this process rules set by congress
imply there cannot be a campaign by the
president nor can public resources be
used for his ratification nevertheless
what we have seen are public servants
from the president's party at every
level basically campaigning for it
some have even argued the vote could
open the door to removing term limits in
a country where presidents are only
allowed to serve a single six-year
mandate outside of the political debate
however many social scholars have argued
the new referendum process is ultimately
a good thing for mexican democracy it is
this and other forms of citizen
participation are important and
necessary as we confront the crisis of
democracies these mechanisms of direct
democracy should serve to empower
citizens in the public space and in the
decision-making process
a recent national survey suggests that
only as much as 27 percent of eligible
voters will participate in the recall
referendum far below the 40 percent
needed for the results to be binding
president lopez obrador however has
vowed to respect the outcome of the
referendum and resign if he receives
less than 50 percent of votes regardless
of voter turnout
though polls have now closed election
officials say it could still take
several days for the official count to
be announced manuel rapalo al jazeera
mexico city